[Music]
living light bulb news living a
lightbulb submitted by water is wet this
human light bulb claims that he feeds on
electricity when he gets hungry I better
not catch him eating one piece of
[ __ ] food I suffer like this you just
mix batteries all day I hope he's eight
he's like I'm hungry sorry my phone
sounds like a [ __ ] Smallville episode
the [ __ ] Adams family member for sure
freak of the week [ __ ] or the TLC
addicted my strange addiction oh yeah so
fuzzy
[ __ ] yeah I just can't picture a plate
of electricity pie or some [ __ ] like I
think it's gotta be the battery thing
looking better looking or he's just
licking the wall sockets like light
bulbs 42 year old nourish she likes to
nourish he's from northern India it was
northern India he claims that he has a
very special gift and that he
accidentally found out about this
special gift when he was at work and he
touched a live wire by mistake and
nothing happened so he was like oh and
so I guess he kept playing with live
wires oh it did it shocked me I know I
gotta do it the kid so instead of like
you know being more careful he was like
I have a superpower so then now read too
many comic oh yeah yeah so now he says
that if there isn't food ready yet at
home cuz he has a wife and kids that if
food isn't ready and he's hungry that he
just sucks on the live wire and for 10
minutes and he'll feel satisfied and
full really how did it come from like ah
I can't get shocked too I could [ __ ]
eat fish if it's like that transition
right there's a quote it's stuck in a
wider [ __ ] does that mean I know and
where do you just getting live wire
apparently there's live wire or exposed
wires all over their home they're not
the kids and the wife and kids aren't
allowed to touch the wires rules wires
that are just plugged into the walls
with no appliance attached to the other
side that shit's going around like a
snake
the hell is going on wasn't this a
spider-man episode like the what's
spider-man BiCMOS unless a mr.
spider-man episode Jewish adventure yeah
mr. spider-man and Friends was it was a
Jamie Foxx's character like the electric
man was he's like it's not alright yeah
I don't know but he fighter in it I like
that's an episode - you like my frickin
mom described something she's like oh I
love all those Lord of the Rings
episodes it's so true that's that's how
they talk you're truly an old lady man
Naresh he says I can touch any
electrical appliance like a television
washing machine fridge and an inverter
with my bare hands and it doesn't affect
me in fact it helps my energy levels I
think about 80% of my body is composed
of electricity now so well it's not he
just made it up apparently there are no
switches in the home it's like all live
wires aren't allowed to touch it but if
they got turn off the light like what's
a fight otherwise says that he handles
all of the electrical things in the
house my husband came in talking about
this should be like you need to sleep
the [ __ ] outside I don't know what drug
you're [ __ ] all but you can't be in
this house with dirty honey I have I
have magic powers I'll show you guys a
quick clip oh hell yeah
this is mine you see whose map nappy yes
I've come for their double cuz him such
a serious look on his face oh [ __ ]
that's it you spin it online don't use
electricity as my source of energy I get
weak what was he trying to show us
Indian robot
the liveWires mouth I could see like a
kid holding it to his house I'm not
really sure what that it looks like a
needle or said in India they have
arranged marriages too so the wife was
just like 10 like that just go I just
can't believe it's like so obvious
what's going on here like how okay if
this is real or whatever how come the
news knows about it like obviously he's
playing this up for [ __ ] press [ __ ]
like he wants attention with all this
[ __ ] like you don't just you don't do
this [ __ ] and then like oh hi news yeah
I eat electricity you know I mean like
how do they find out no I always I'm
always curious about the stories of it
maybe it's a rumor I know like in the
village and in the journalists is like
goes to investigate and he's like I
heard of this electricity man well give
me Bob over there yeah but that rumor
will be so interesting right like it's
like it's like um I've seen a guy who
just you know puts a wire in his mouth
and has it like like a light bulb
attached to it like that's a rumor like
it's like I've seen it like yeah you go
over there it's right there
yeah it's so weird weird yeah I don't
understand I mean I understand why he's
doing it other than like like I said
people were taking pictures of it
videoing it well yeah Bentley now in
that region they call him the human
light bulb maybe he wants to be a part
of the Indian circus yeah and it's
always been a dream of his but they
don't like his resume cuz they're like
that's not special and then so he has to
build his own like fan base so it's like
finally he could be a part of the circus
that's a thing how does this work is
this like a I feel like bar do you know
you know how this works fake pranks if
the wires going into his mouth is it
where's it plugged into okay welcome
this angle are ghetto okay you know what
it'd be dope it's like one side of it if
in his mouth and the other one is
plugged to his butthole and he's
conducting the electricity like this
that's something that would be sick I
paid to see this yeah but it's just a
wire that's going through his mouth
right it doesn't look like it's exposed
either just like I kind of want to see
him get taste see what happens I mean
right on the tongue there so I could
just be
snap yeah just get stronger crazy do
some cooler [ __ ] how long has he been
eating electricity for now they don't
mention him he's kind of a peasant no
like he's just eating like these smaller
wires
I'd be going outside fighting with a
big-ass wire and have a buffet there you
go no electricity snacks you should be
you know like electricity state like the
big version of it that's true I could
give them some car battery yeah put the
two things I just yeah that's my problem
is I think I've seen so much similar
[ __ ] that I'm not that impressed by this
like if he had a nuclear power plant
[ __ ] thing is now I'd be like yes
let's watch this [ __ ] yeah especially
with the Internet you see so much [ __ ]
now that even fake [ __ ] exact you know
it's fake but it's like okay so like I'm
like it's like hi I was in a car
accident 20 years ago and I have a
steering wheel through my chest how are
you like that shit's interesting to me
I'm like he kept the steering wheel and
it's [ __ ] chest like what what's his
story how do you [ __ ] you got a scale on
your chest and [ __ ] like but this guy's
just like yeah you know I run no Wyatt
they're not a little it's a little wired
have you guys ever had the feeling of
electricity going through your body
before like you guys got in a shock yeah
because like once I've plugged something
into the outlet and I just felt like
something sharp to shoot up my arm it
was like oh my god it's gonna be one of
those things in the cartoon so I'm just
like this the whole time I don't want to
know what to do because I couldn't let
go and well you couldn't let go yeah it
just made you like scared I get stuck
you get stuck too so that's why in my
head I was playing like oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna be one of those cartoons they're
like I can't let go and then I'll just
be burnt to a crisp I will use I can't
believe you didn't think that was cool
though I'm like a cartoon
I would have died because I would have
been doing that [ __ ] together click the
curtain while I'm sticking Forks in a
was this thinking forks I was just like
plugging something in port I full-on got
electrified by a goat fence oh yeah my
idiot uncle raised goats big and then
and then he decided eventually he was
like you know what's less profitable
than that emus yeah I'll trade him out
for a minute but no but yeah so the cat
had he had a goat fence or whatever so I
stuck my arm over it to go in there cuz
you know you go in there to pet the go
through some [ __ ] and so I'm I watch my
arm just to fly back behind me oh [ __ ]
and I started like falling down and
standing up and falling down and
standing up and going down standing up
you lost control of your body I lost
complete control of my body and you just
kept automatically doing things like
like like after one shot I look like
[ __ ] Robocop you know it was kind of
sick in that way like as a memory like
you know how like Murphy's like he's
like a problem problem that's crazy yeah
like it was it was very odd I could feel
it all night
I could feel in my body like all night
like like some kind of like I'd be like
I know 13 14 years old you deserved it
Thanks just from one zap like that it
was a lot all this electricity in your
body and yours I don't know that it was
that but whatever it was I felt tingly
all night like for sure you should have
tried putting your fingers in the air
and then opening your mouth to see if
you can hear the radio like come out of
your mouth no why didn't I think of that
no no you know I see because you're a
stupid kid you think maybe I heard you
have powers now yes and then you know I
tried running my hand underwater and she
had to see if I could make static or
whatever had electricity going through
you and I didn't have like a lot I
didn't I was like do they have like
there's kids walking around with like a
car battery and they like you you pay
them however much money they charge you
for it and then Mexicans they like to
hold on to it and get a lecture by
electrocuted for like a quick like jolt
of energy or whatever why it's like
cheap-ass energy drinks what do you do
give them a quarter and a pencil and
there you go
and you're like oh yeah let me turn it
on go yeah I saw my dad's because my dad
does weird [ __ ] and so I thought him I
was like what was that he was and I'm
like what did you do he was like have my
morning Joel do you know I get cranky
but I'm a Joel why are you actually pay
to get electrocuted
you should have bought him some
batteries so he could just lick on those
yeah 12 volts - those are great I
remember doing that [ __ ] sometimes you
know your life's boring and you got to
spice it up with some electrocution
that's right that's right
electrifying yeah you well yeah if
you're electrocuted you're dead
afterwards I know that because I told
that story for years and some kids were
always like if you're electrocuting your
dad you can't say that you're
electrified get electrocuted you're dead
just like you know my age like 14
electrocuted means that you're done you
died from electrocution yourself at
least from all the children that I grew
up with oh no you should keep it on I
don't want to hear the anti wanna be
right no it's all those kids that would
be right no I would be right because I
used the executed injure or kill someone
by Linder oh my god can you cut that out
wait please cut it hey guys I hope you
enjoyed that episode of just kidding
News and if there's a story that you
guys want us to talk about go ahead down
into our description box below and
there's a link there where you can
submit articles for the next video click
right up here
[Music]